11 mai a priori de 19h à 20h on ferait
une émission voilà sur un plateau un
petit peu bucolique
voilà je vous dit on seraient trois ou
quatre chroniqueurs avec des images des
défis pétanque fléchettes dark ale
baballe un plâtre enfin voilà avec votre
tête est de retour avec des images etc
voilà on va voir on en train de faire ça
bien sûr sans public pour l'instant en
comité très restreint
mais voilà pour retrouver un petit peu
de rigolade ça s'appellera encore ce
soir chez ba ba voilà ça c'est sûr et
derrière on est en train d'essayer de
monter bien sûr en plateau donc aussi
avec 24 candidats
voilà son public mais il y aura les 24
candidats et il y aura donc un candidat
qui va jouer à prendre ou à laisser
donc le vrai à prendre même si on avait
des gens voici donc à prendre ou à
laisser les chéris avec les boîtes
voilà qui qui reviendrait certainement
peut-être pas le 11 mai voilà je pense
que ça arrivera plutôt famille voilà ce
sera à la suite de ce soir chez ba ba et
voilà on aura donc les bois boîte qui
vont arriver les chéris la chaîne voit
là bas m'a proposé de l'animé donc je
suis très heureux voilà et je sais qu'il
ya plein de gens qui disent syrie située
à nîmes les bois bois essayer de les
ouvrir plus vite et il y aura bien sûr
et je vous le dis une boîte jusqu'à 250
voilà donc il y aura des serait très
très brillant voilà ce sera les vrais
sinon ce sera les vrais barbade 24
candidats un candidat qui va venir jouer
avec moi et on le fera à leur petite
nouveauté c'est vrai que ça n'a jamais
été fait on va faire à prendre ou à
laisser
en direct voilà la réponse vint donc
voila et vous pourrez gagner la moitié
de la somme également chez vous comme
dans le jeu original
voilà est-ce que vous trouvez que c'est
une bonne idée de ce que dit la vérité
franchement bonne ce qui est bien les
boîtes gilles là mais 100 milliards et
en plus avec vous avec la tête de c je
me vois déjà
honnêtement je vous le dirai si j'aime
pas mais là franchement j'ai hyper envie
de voir ça ça va être fantastique
j'aimerais bien avoir l'avis de remo et
bastien sacrément ya plus de batterie
home angie mon chéri c'est une très
bonne idée de sanctionner l'un des
meilleurs jeux depuis dix ans au
quotidien sur tf1 et bouger parfum
d'adam g ac j'ai hâte de voir ici mais
30 ans pourrait le faire elle va avec
grand plaisir mon benji franchement avec
grand plaisir avec grand plaisir et tu
serais très bons aussi valérie qu'est ce
t'en pense ma chérie ouais moi je moi
j'adore ce jeu moi je suis je suis
dingue de ce jeu je trouve que il est
d'une simplicité biblique et en même
temps absolument diabolique
donc voilà je suis totalement ramé qui
avoient l'animation j'espère que vous
aurez avec moi j'espère que vous en
ferez avec moi un vautour en bien
parfois on en mettra peut-être certains
quelquefois derrière derrière une boîte
sophie koch non mais moi j'avais adoré
quand je connaissais pas du tout en fait
ce jeu commence à virer les bois battre
vous avez vous gagné une somme colossale
je crois que c'est cinquante mille euros
il y avait un suspense de dengue une
émotion enfin voila si vous arrivez à
recréer ça sur ce jeu là franchement
c'est 100% sais pas encore je mange et
j'ai hâte de le faire en plateau jouée
en direct avec vous téléspectateurs
je vais me régaler jean miché que tu
adores se jettent aussi je crois que
c'est passé sous pression mais je
meilleurs jeux d
année c'est d'une activité d'une
perversion terrible et dans cette
perversion vous êtes génial parce que
vous arrivez à on a sa boîte
on sait jamais si vous la rendre la
garder jusqu'à la fin du jeu on est
perdu et c'est fantastique parce qu'à
chaque fois plus à chaque fois il ya des
brugeois de la fin si vous avez de cette
chance ouais donc une décision sur tout
juste du kentucky qui pour le banquier
en train de voir mais ce sera les
banques et puisque bouder la rampe voilà
qu'avec irek m merzouk sarah lavaud
raymond beauchamp
moi je suis moi je suis très content
c'est une très bonne nouvelle parce que
pour être franc j'ai aimé le jeu quand
c'est arthur qu'il faisait j'aime le jeu
quand c'était génial combet a bien donné
mais avec vous aussi parce que j'adore
cette mécanique de suspense qui a on se
retrouve après la pub le banquier a fait
une offre
on sait que les gens parfois entre l'as
du banquier c'est des grosses sommes
et moi je me dis comment les gens
peuvent refuser des offres comme ça
j'adore cette émission est juste une
question est ce que c'est vous qui allez
présenter tout le temps parce que j'ai
des bruits de couloir dans mon
confinement dit que vous allez comment
je te met peut-être c'est quelqu'un
d'autre tu vas te présenter c'est bien
vous
pour l'instant c'est pour l'instant
voilà pour l'instant on va voir on va en
faire une salle je pense d'une d'une
quinzaine de jeux voilà après on verra
voilà et mais voilà pour l'instant c'est
moi qui vais le présenter en tout cas
les laisserait j'avais écrit en direct
certains ça n'a jamais été son directeur
c'est la première fois voilà pour ma
famille on direct voilà sa cage et qui
arrivera ça arrivera on mais je vous le
dis certainement la fin mais je vous
dirai pas son camp ça arrive
on est en train de travailler ça pour
vous proposer encore une autre offre
donc je vous aurez votre séchoir ce soir
c'est le ba ba et vous aurez également à
jean michel et sony 17e jour si quelques
jours de suite les gens gagnent 250 me
vous n'avez pas finir par faire la
guerre eh bien écoutez on fermera la
boutique on sera heureux au moins eu les
gens heureux on sera content